everyone this is kevin from the chest
website com super excited to let
everyone know we're going to be having
our most exciting giveaway yet we're
going to be giving away a ton of prizes
first things we're going to be giving
away our two different sets of fritz 12
for its if you're not familiar is one of
the leading chess software engines
that's out there so many people use
software these days powerful powerful
engines to study positions deep analysis
on a game you can run your own games
through Fritz to give analysis to kind
of see where you go wrong if it's in the
middle game the in game maybe in the
openings if you don't do well so many of
you send me your own games and say hey
can you analyze this for me with Fritz
that will actually do it for you again
if you want training it has training up
here so much stuff that you can do in
here very very valuable tool we're going
to be giving away two of these for free
if you want some information about
fridge 12 you can head over to chess
central com this is pretty much going to
be the cheapest place that you can find
for 12 but it does have a nice
description here about the software all
the different things it can do again
it's probably one of the most powerful
tools out there if your chess player and
you don't have it I highly recommend it
again chest central comm this is where I
got deep aquarium so that's what I you
or where did you get that I got it from
chess central calm and again i use ripka
aquarium so you can get that here again
fritsch 12 i'll have the link in the
description if you want to check it out
and find out more about rich 12 they
also have you know books if you want
books if you want you know chess sets
I've got a chess set from here as well
so tons of exciting stuff on this page
but we're going to be giving away again
two sets of fridge 12 for free doesn't
matter where you live you can't enter
second thing we're going to be giving
away is a full set of the chess website
DVD so this has not only some of the
dvds from the website but I've also made
a ton of videos that are not included on
the website so if you really want to get
better as far as in-depth analysis of
the middle game as far as pawns trucks
and center control all these different
topics I get into on these dvds so we're
going to be giving away a set of DVD so
you're probably wondering okay there's
ton of great prizes what do I have to do
to enter
so I'm going to be going over the rules
to enter the contest you can probably
tell from my screen right now or your
screen however you look at it is i'm now
on twitter i joined on twitter on april
eleventh i haven't done too many tweets
just because i didn't want to start
tweeting really until i made this video
many of you are probably looking and
being like hey there's kevin's pitcher
this the first time I've seen Kevin
that's what he looks like yes that's me
so I am now on Twitter and after this
post is made i will start tweeting so
what are some of the things i'm going to
be tweeting about so many people always
ask me hey Kevin when you get on chest
calm i would like to play you I think
it'd be beneficial with while we play
you help me along in the game I've got
to do that with many of you many of you
I still haven't got to do that I'm much
better about playing in real time then
you sending me an invite to play over
like five days because then I just
forget so that's what I'm going to be
tweeting about when I'm on if you
message me you know at the chess website
calm and say hey you want to play i'll
probably get on and play so i'll be
using it for that also i'll be tweeting
about stuff not related chest so like
many of you I enjoy things not related
to chess so i'll be posting about that
but i also am very interested in chess
so if there's a big news story out there
or if there's a tournament going on i'll
be posting about that a lot of people
always ask me when new updates come out
so if there's a new update to the
website i'll be posting that on here or
if there's an update to youtube there's
a new video i'll be posting on here
anything i deem necessary i'll be
posting on here so i think it's
definitely going to be worthwhile so
definitely follow me on twitter that's
the first one the second one is to make
a tweet or post whatever you want to
call it that links to the chess website
so the chess website looks like this if
you've never been here or never seen
this I don't know where you've been for
the last two years but this is the
website the chest open site com so make
a poster tweet that links to that
somewhere in your description and the
last one is at the end of your tweet I
want you to put pound EHS now many of
you that are probably Twitter
for a long time are familiar with this
someone told me that if you put pound
the HS at the end then I can search any
search field pound the HS and see
everyone that's put that on there so I'm
going to take people's advice and that's
what we're going to do pound the HS that
time with a search and see who has
entered the contest so again follow me
on Twitter make a tweet this says
somewhere in there that links to the
website it could be you know one of
those tiny urls whatever as long as it
links to the chess website that's fine
and at the end of your tweet put pound
DHS so I know you're trying to enter to
win one of the fritz software's or
you're trying to win the DVD package now
here are the time frame so you actually
have two chances to win so if you don't
win the first time you can win the
second time the first software set is
going to be given out on Sunday night so
right now it's Friday night for me so
you're going to have two days to enter
and I will be tweeting the winter so you
don't need to post on this video and say
who won the contest I'm not going to
post it here i'm going to post it on
Twitter because i'm now twittering so
look on there after Sunday after I
announced the winner then it's going to
reset and there's going to be another
two days so on Tuesday night I'm going
to announce another winner so if you
didn't win the first time same rules
apply I'm going to look for y HS who
posted that from Sunday to Tuesday and
then I'm going to announce another
winner so again you've probably already
following me make another post or tweet
that links to the chess website and put
Y HS and you will be entered to win so
that's how you win the fritz if you want
to win the DVD package I'm going to
pretty much take all four days so
doesn't matter when you entered as long
as you enter within those four days
you'll be eligible I'll pick one winner
out and then let you know through
Twitter that you have won the DVD
package so pretty cool again who doesn't
like free stuff pretty easy thing to do
so if you're not already on Twitter I
definitely recommend getting on just to
win the prizes if you are already on
Twitter again just at the chess website
calm so if you have any questions feel
free to
leave it on here you can always tweet me
Twitter me I don't know what the correct
phrases I'll probably learn as time goes
on again if you have any questions on
fritz you can go back to chess central
com most of the questions you may have
will be here so if you just want to buy
it yourself you can do that here if you
have questions about it you can do it
here or if there's another software if
you're like I'm not really fritz but I
want ripka aquarium kind of like kevin
has you can get that here as well so
again twitter follow me and make a post
and i hope you guys win good luck and
I'll see you guys on Twitter but